[Música]
todo el tiempo nos estamos preocupando
por tener más dinero comprar una mejor
casa bajar de peso pero nos preocupamos
por tener una mente positiva
tristemente cada vez se nos olvida más
eso imagínate que yo te digo te voy a
poner a una persona al lado de ti 12
horas diarias todo el día va a estar
contigo y esa persona te va a criticar
te va a humillar te ofenderte va a
tratar mal a diestra y siniestra pero
también lo va a hacer con tus familiares
amigos y compañeros te gustaría que esta
persona te siguiera
estas personas somos nosotros está
comprobado hay un estudio que dice que
nos hablamos de 12 a 14 horas diarias o
sea que tienes una vocecita aquí que
todo el tiempo te está diciendo estás
manejando y te dice hoy qué tonta es la
de al lado ya viste no le han de haber
enseñado bueno pero tú tampoco sabes
manejar vas a chocar de todas maneras te
vas a morir aquí estás trabajando y tu
jefe no te quiere mejor ve por una
galleta de todas maneras tus compañeros
te odian te estás bañando y la vocecita
hoy de la regadera está toda sucia ni
siquiera eso puedes hacer bien y qué
cuerpo tan feo tienes nadie te va a
querer esa vocecita te dice de 12 a 14
horas diarias y lo repito para que les
quede muy claro cuál es el plan les voy
a dar 10 puntos con estos 10 puntos
vamos a poder hacer que esta vocecita
pase de negativo a positivo les prometo
que si me ponen atención vamos a cambiar
mucho
mentir es el número uno
todo el tiempo estamos mintiendo
mentimos por omisión por tratar de carne
bien al de al lado por justificar nos
por salir de un problema la típica por
exageración pero si me comí tres
pasteles y te comiste ocho pasteles
dices y estás en el gps y dices si llego
ahorita en diez minutitos y el gps dice
18 porque no decirle 18 pero todo el
tiempo estamos mintiendo obviamente
cuando mentimos segregamos substancias
que nos hacen daño y es como si
estuvieras tomando una agua con veneno
diario cada vez que te mientes solamente
es a alguien porque también nos mentimos
a nosotros te vas envenenando
envenenando envenenando entonces la
actividad que les quiero dar que es como
una tarea en cada uno de los puntos les
voy a dar una tarea la tarea es
cimientos
analiza las notas en un papelito en tu
celular en donde sea y te fijas qué
hubiera pasado si no hubieras mentido
cómo te sentirías si eso lo hubiera
sometido pero recuerda que si dices una
mentira sin amor es crueldad
imagínate que acaba de nacer tu sobrino
más con tu hermana al hospital y te dice
mira qué bonito mi bebé
así que dices la verdad no hay sino la
dices pero
dice es una verdad con amor y la verdad
es hermana no importa lo bueno es que
está sana y el bebé está muy bien que
justo me da y así este es el ejemplo que
les boda la que sigue es libérate todo
el tiempo a cada hora estamos criticando
suponiendo chismeando envidiando y
quejándonos obviamente que por ejemplo
la crítica existe la crítica
constructiva y la crítica destructiva
entonces aquí en esta charla vamos a
hablar sólo de la negatividad
sabes que tú criticas que es lo que
realmente estás haciendo si sabes estás
viendo tus carencias en el otro cuando
yo te critico a ti es porque estoy
viendo lo que me falta algo que me
necesito lo que te choca te checa se
sabe la ley del espejo buenísima supones
suponemos el 80% del tiempo
la típica llegas con tu jefe o con tus
papás y de éstos por emocionado porque
les quieres contar una meta que lograste
e a lo que vas a hacer y les empiezas a
contar y de repente así ellos terminan
la frase
y continúan eso no está nada padre te
gusta pues no te baja la moral ya no te
dan ganas de contarle si ya tienes hasta
la idea 16 y hasta aquí ya llegué pero
es algo normal entonces lo que te invito
es a que dejes de suponer no supongas
como es la otra persona no supongas que
va a ser mi que va a decir deja que
hable
chiquito lo expliqué la otra es el
chisme esto realmente es una arma verbal
porque todo el tiempo estamos chisme a
mover cosas que ni siquiera nos constan
y si nos constan nos importa realmente
te importa que la vecina tiene un amante
no estás nada más lastimando te fíjate
cuando dices un chisme sientes como un
el que hacer será secante
porque estás agregando cosas negativas
para tu cuerpo y para tu cerebro
me gusta que existen de ti
a mí tampoco me gusta que no le gusta
nadie a nadie le gusta que estéis mente
de nadie entonces tú quieres que noches
cuando te empieza por tu casa empresa
por ti la envidia
la envidia es el deseo de tener lo que
el otro tiene
qué prefieres envidiar o actuar entonces
mejor deja de envidiar al prójimo y
aprende qué es lo que está haciendo como
lo está haciendo cómo está llegando ahí
y da un salto para que tú también lo
puedas tener
es muy triste pensar que la envidia es
sólo un deseo de que no estás tan guapa
tan alta tan rico tan delgado o lo que
sea eso está horrible cuando lo ves así
tal cual crudo es fatal la que sea
la que todo el tiempo está tu vas a un
restaurante y de repente tu amiga dice
hoy la carne de este pedazo está crudo y
se está cake de arte si dices mesero por
favor cambien la carne se la cambia ni
kicker es ella sigue quejándose se suben
al carro se sigue quejando van al súper
se sigue quejando es el día siguiente se
sigue quejando y en redes y se sigue
quejando la queja no te lleva a nada no
sé ustedes para mí me toca estar con
gente que se queja se queje se queja y
no actúa te estás quejando actuar
intenta cambiarlo no haces nada para
cambiarlo entonces aclimatar oac
lichinga te como dicen por ahí por
ejemplo está mal tu calle tiene baches y
entonces te quejaste quejas te quedas
todos los días pues puede juntar firmas
de quejarte con alguien pero por escrito
hasta algún vídeo un documental es algo
para que cambien deja de quejarte
la acción que vamos a hacer aquí es
darnos un pequeño golpecito imagínense
que esto es una liga entonces me voy a
dar un golpecito o un pellizco un zape
me voy a comer un chile algo que no me
guste cada vez que hagamos algunas de
estas cosas nos vamos a hacer un daño
porque porque a nadie le gusta sufrir y
así nos vamos a ir dando cuenta cuántas
veces sufrimos al día
el control
una cosa es controlar y otra es planear
el planear te sirva muchísimo porque
entonces puedes ver que cómo va a ir el
itinerario a analizarlo bien es
educativo fomenta etcétera pero el
control lo único que haces es manipular
a los otros si tú tratas de manipular
los otros realmente crees que lo vas a
lograr
no podemos ni siquiera controlar cuando
vamos al baño auto puedes decidir en qué
momento porque entonces creerías que
puedes controlar a todos los demás
la acción que vamos a hacer para esto
para detenernos es calla escucha analiza
y piensa si es planeación o control y
así puedes hacer un gran cambio en tu
vida a parte de nadie le gusta que lo
controle
el cuerpo esto es algo fundamental
saben que si tenemos el equilibrio bien
pues evidentemente vamos a dar un mejor
rendimiento una buena alimentación hacer
ejercicio te provoca muchos también
químicos buenos para poder hacer una un
balance con los químicos de las mentiras
la crítica y etcétera y dormir bien
porque si no todos aquí hemos dormido
mal y no estás de buen humor y no das el
rendimiento ni nada
la acción que les invito aquí es que de
nutrición por favor vayan con un
nutriólogo verdad porque no tengo tiempo
voy a decirle esto está muy largo ya
vieron al doctor y dejen de hacer sus
dietas de internet o de la amiga lo que
hace el vecino lo que dice una revista
por favor tomen lo en serio la otra es
hacer ejercicio 20 minutos tres veces a
la semana y dormir de 6 a 8 horas mínimo
un diario
aquí estaba muy fácil
y nos regresamos pero que no están muy
bien también por allá filtros de
información diariamente tenemos mucha
información que nos llega negativa ya
sea visual o auditiva por redes sociales
internet televisión radio etcétera tú
qué crees que le pasa a tu cerebro no sé
si sepan pero el cerebro no sabe
diferenciar entre la realidad y la
ficción es solamente
reacciones entonces vamos a poner un
ejemplo muy claro estamos viendo una
película de terror sentados y de repente
te empiezas a alterar te pones nervioso
tu sudor huele diferente te estresas te
irritas te preocupas hasta puedes llorar
tú crees que de verdad tu cerebro sabe
distinguir qué estás viendo una serie
una película no porque químicamente a él
lo están asustando puntos se acabó
entonces si tú quieres evitar tener
estas cosas negativas en tu vida pues
bájale un poquito las noticias si es que
tal te alteran también vas en el carro
cantando todos me odian nadie me quiere
porque el mundo es horrible pues te lo
vas creyendo porque al final eso es
neurolingüística y llega a tu cerebro
para que tú puedes borrar ese tipo de
información que estás cantando y sobre
todo si la estás sintiendo ya sabes
paquita la del barrio así
tienes que escuchar la escuchaste 16
veces se queda grabada en tu cerebro
para siempre a menos de que escuches 32
veces de algo que sea justo lo diferente
para que puedas revertir el daño
entonces mi consejo para aquí es
mantente ocupado en tus tiempos libres
por ejemplo yo cuando estoy bañando
cocinando o manejando lo que hago es
escuchar audios positivos y esto es con
podcast conferencias de tef
obviamente audiolibros y así está puedo
aprender y lo que hago es que mi
vocecita la pago porque por estar
poniendo atención en el vídeo ya no está
ahí alegando mi cabeza es súper bueno se
los recomiendo
y luego está el agradecimiento esto es
básico y hasta venía en la biblia sino
agradeces no te caben más bendiciones
aparte es muy importante porque la gente
también está buscando eso de ti todos
buscamos el agradecimiento porque si tú
esperas que te digan gracias tú no las
dices lo que les voy a decir aquí es que
hay que valorarse hay que valorar a los
demás y la actividad aquí es que por
favor todo el día mínimo le digas a
cinco personas gracias mínimo pero sos
un súper mínimo porque cuando estás
sucio el baño de la oficina clases
reclamarlo quejarte pero cuando está
limpio que el 90% del tiempo está limpio
basile y se oiga señora gracias por
tener tan limpio la oficina gracias por
tener limpiar los baños por poner papel
nunca estamos diciendo gracias si tu
papá llega por ti tarde a la escuela te
pones con más furia pero te pones super
linda y amable y dices gracias todos los
demás días que si van entonces por favor
agradecimiento es súper básico el otro
es el perdón
de qué le sirve el rencor dígame solo a
una cosa alguien se le ocurre algo aquí
algo positivo que decir para qué te
sirve el rencor
sin embargo todos tenemos culpas y
rencor eso no te sirve de nada el rencor
no es solamente un cuchillo que te la
pasás haciéndote así a ti mismo porque
hay afuera al que odias imagínate que es
un pedrito a pedrito lo odio y le tengo
rencor enojo y odio
y yo siento súper feo y me enojo y me
pongo triste y no puedo dormir bien y no
soy feliz pero a pedrito le darle un
reverendo chipotle de nuevo pero no le
importa porque lo estás sintiendo ese
coraje el rencor o un arma que te daña a
ti mismo
aquí está buenísima la tarea no te la da
la tarea es que cuando estés enojado con
alguien cuando le tengo rencor a alguien
hagas una carta primero de todo lo que
te molesta de esa persona exagerada
súper exagerada por ejemplo el
calentamiento global es tu culpa subí 15
kilos por tu culpa o lo que sea su culpa
y creen que super en la carta pero
después hacen otra carta y la otra carta
va a tener todas las cosas buenas y
lindas no importa que sea que tiene las
uñas limpias o los zapatos boleados el
caso es que hagas las dos cartas y por
tres noches vas a estar pensando en
todas las cosas buenas del tal pedrito
luego sigue
actúa e imagina por favor vuelta el lado
derecho y sonríe la persona que está a
tu lado sonríe
vieron que lindo se siente como se rompe
el ambiente
hay veces que no precisamente tienes que
estar feliz de corazón para poder actuar
lo y después ser feliz se acuerdan que
les dije que tu cerebro no distingue
entre la verdad y la ficción pues
tampoco para la felicidad
entonces sonríen en la vida que más da
de todas maneras ya estás en el tráfico
pues ya ponte a cantar no te queda de
nada darle quejando al de al lado
haciendo cosas malas no te funcionan y
la acción que les recomiendo aquí es
todas las mañanas antes de que veas el
celular que te parece al baño antes de
nada
cierras tus ojos y piensas en un momento
en el que te sentiste muy feliz esta
foto fue un día estaba muy muy feliz
un día que tuviste mucho éxito que te
sentías lleno de gozo cuando haces eso
en la mañana empiezas tu mañana on fire
con todo te paras y te pones a sonreír
si no tienes ganas de sonreír no importa
porque puedes actuar como ya vimos que
si se puede
luego personas que suman hay personas
que realmente solamente te meten en un
ciclo para abajo y hay personas que si
tienen las mismas visión que tú las
mismas ambiciones pues te llenan
entonces la tarea de aquí va a ser hacer
una lista de las personas que realmente
tienen objetivos positivos y que les
puedes aprender con esas personas te vas
a juntar más con las personas que no
tienen cosas positivas que no más bien
te restan dinero pasión ganas
perseverancia los cortas por lo sano
así es tu familia o si son compañeros de
trabajo que a fuerza les tienes que
hablar hablarles lo menos posible porque
te contaminan cómo quiere ser no te
juntes con gente que no quiere ser como
ellos
y por último disfruta y amate tú te
tratas como te trataría de cifras hoy te
vas a casar con brad pitt y brandy te
encanta cómo trataría esa brad pitt
tú te tratas así a ti te hablas así si
tú tratarás así al amor de tu vida se
van en dos días si no es que menos por
favor trata de cómo te deberías de
tratar
por otro lado
les voy a decir que a mí me ha costado
mucho trabajo llegar a donde estoy pero
lo que me tiene aquí es la perseverancia
la pasión y la confianza puse una
empresa de piñatas y se burlaban porque
me hacían la piñata era porque no lo iba
a lograr al final gracias a dios llevo
un pedacito de méxico a todo el mundo y
eso me hace muy feliz pero ser una
empresaria exitosa no es lo que
realmente llena mi corazón mi corazón lo
llena
realmente mi hija que esto no está
planeado pero ella es mi hija la tuve
cuando yo tenía 17 años
eso no me detuvo para estar donde estoy
y gracias a ella realmente llena mi
motor y mi vida por favor tengan una
mente positiva por ellos por este mundo
por su familia por sus amigos háganlo
por ustedes pero háganlo por ellos yo
quiero cambiar y lo quiero hacer por
ella deja muy gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y